you know what's great about the wild
ride clips channel is that we just serve
up
exactly what you want in bite size clips
and you know what's good about doordash
they bring it to you every bite you want
so thanks to doordash for hooking up
this dope clip yeah and i know you guys
like i remember the like the logan paul
situation like i i saw about that that
was like i'm not trying to give like
advice to people who aren't looking for
advice
with the ones i'm i'm i'm i i i'm all
listen i'm modeling your advice let me
tell you what i'm gonna i'm gonna
explain to you did you see the way how
he was coming let me explain to you why
that was they had a motive let me tell
you why because i i i i love when people
give me advice because you are someone
that looks at me right
and uh from third person view and you
might peep something that i don't pee
you know what i'm saying so like i don't
have a problem with someone giving
advice it's the way how you come at me
all right and stuff like that and i feel
like he came at me like almost trying to
test him but he he's texting my jewelry
he made a gay comment already uh uh
you're trying to be a comedian yeah
yesterday it was he was kind of being a
dick i'm just condescending for sure i
only saw the one part sorry yeah you saw
the snippet part where i'm i'm just
being honest i'm just being honest we
went there with good vibes how we came
here and it's so funny he mentioned the
jewelry oh sell your drew you go bro we
just upgraded her i don't
listen and everyone was like why don't
you take us back i i listen i take
advice from people all day long i take
advice from him i take advice from him i
take advice from anybody i even take
advice from people that are not as
successful as me like you know i like to
hear what people have to say about me
okay
and these guys agree
no i know i know but if you're if you're
telling me in a dick way like to sell my
jewelry
that i wouldn't that i work for as a
young child maybe praying on my downfall
maybe if you go broke you can sell your
jewelry you know what else and you know
what else i noticed that i used my hand
and i'm like oh at first they asked this
so how does it feel that we made it and
we were humbled by them we're like you
know we want to make it farther
congratulations at first and then and
then at the end they were like so what
if you guys don't make it so they were
they had a motive they were trying to
focus on that makes that makes perfect
sense to me and and and i'm glad to i'm
glad that we got to
get your uh take on that you know like i
i i absolutely agree that like paul said
the guy was being addicted to that guy
though first time i heard about it i
clicked on it i skipped ahead just to
the part where you guys walked off just
because i was curious yeah i was like
okay and then he laughed and he laughed
he laughed at it uh after and he paid us
for a video to put on his instagram so
so that's what i'm saying he had on
tiramisu but but i'm just saying last
night was the first time i was like oh
we're having him on the show like i
should watch this whole thing and i was
like these guys [ __ ] rule and he kind
of was being a dick like yeah bro you
watched the whole thing and there's
people that think that we were being
dicks yeah people like being hard on us
i mean because we what because we walked
out and we said that you know i said a
couple things or whatever the case might
be i mean i mean bro you made me mad bro
it is what it is i walked off and i'm
you're not going to play me like i'm
stupid there's a big difference i have a
i have a brand and i and i just how
stevois brand you know he different ways
of protecting his brand just he has
different different well we're saying we
have different ways to pretend to bear
and i'm not going to sit there and have
someone just clown on me and say yeah i
love it i love it and and again i'm glad
that we that we uh
got to touch on that and the the only
advice that i care to give you okay is
that i just [ __ ] don't want you guys
getting shot i'd like i
just wanna i don't want like we we move
we definitely
i i'm afraid of guns i don't like i love
you i love it
if you go and download the door dash app
and enter the promo code stevo they're
going to hook you up on your first order
man i'm talking 25
for orders of 15
or more and that's up to a 10 value and
zero delivery fees when you're just
getting the most convenient delivery
service on top of that telling you
doordash is the way to make life simple
and get what you want and what you need
when you want it when you need it so one
more time let's go and download the door
dash app and enter the promo code stevo
you can get whatever you want delivered
quick and easy and you'll get that
killer deal on your first order